METE ATAMEL: Hello, everyone.
So my name is Mete Atamel.
I am a developer
advocate at Google.
And today we're going
to talk about taking
your ASP.NET apps to the
next level with Google Cloud.
Before I start my talk,
I have some books,
"Google Cloud for
.NET Developers" here.
So if you're interested,
stop by after my talk
and I'll be happy
to give these away.
And then a little bit of
information about myself.
This doesn't work.
So this is my Twitter,
my email, and my blog.
If you have any questions about
any of this stuff I say today,
feel free to reach out to me.
As I mentioned, I'm
a developer advocate.
I'm based in London.
But it's always
great to be here.
By the way, we also have
Twitter handles, #windowsongcp.
So we're going to be tweeting
about Windows and .NET
on Google Cloud
from this hashtag.
And I'm going to also share
my presentation with you
on #windowsongcp at
#googlenext hashtags.
So you don't have to take
pictures if you don't want to.
I'll share my presentation.
All right, so first of all,
it's a great time to be a .NET
developer.
For years and years and years--
by the way, who
is .NET over here?
Great, yes.
So you know what
I'm talking about.
For years and years, we've been
constrained to Windows world.
We have all this good stuff with
C#, Visual Studio, PowerShell,
SQL Server.
And it was frustrating for
me to just do that on Windows
because I had to do stuff
on Linux once in a while,
and I had to switch my
tools, switch my databases,
all that kind of stuff.
But now with ASP.NET Core,
you can target Linux.
With SQL Server
now, runs on Linux.
PowerShell runs on Linux.
Bash from Linux runs on Windows.
So it is truly a great time
to be a .NET developer.
And at Google, we are trying
to help with this revolution
with Google Cloud.
So this talk is
about that basically.
I just want to show you what
kind of stuff we are doing
to help with .NET developers
running on Google Cloud.
So the agenda today
is first, I want to--
well I'd like to start my
presentation with answering why
first before I show you how.
So the why here is, why should
you even care about Google
Cloud when it comes
to .NET development?
So I want to go through that
and make sure that it's crystal
clear to you guys why you should
even care about Google Cloud
when it comes to .NET developer.
And once we answer
that question,
I want to talk about moving your
existing .NET apps to Google
Cloud.
So I'm going to show
you a simple app running
on my laptop.
And then we're going to look
at how we can take that app
and move to Google Cloud.
So the point here is to show
you how easy it is, basically,
to have what you have
today and move it.
Once we do that, once you have
your app running in the cloud,
you have all these services
and all these tools
that become available to you.
So we're going to take our
application to the next level.
We want to use Cloud Storage.
We're going to use
PowerShell cmdlets.
Visual Studio plug-ins.
We're going to use
machine learning
with Vision API and
Speech API, and just
show you how easy it is, once
you have your app running
in the cloud, to
basically enhance
your application
with the services
that Google Cloud provides.
And then finally, it's fun
to work on fun features,
but then you need to make your
application production ready.
So you need to have logging.
You need to have
error reporting.
You need to have autoscaling.
You need to have load balancing.
These are boring tasks,
but everyone has to do it.
So I just want to show
you what kind of tools
we provide to make
that easy for you.
So this is the agenda.
So let's just answer
the question first.
The first question that
you probably have is,
Windows Server, SQL
Server, ASP.NET on Google,
what's happening, right?
Because Google is
known for many things.
Google is known for
machine learning.
Google is known for search.
Google is known for
Java and Python.
We supported Java and Python
for a long time on App Engine.
We invented Go, and Go
is really popular now.
So when you think
about .NET and C#,
you don't really think
about Google Cloud,
up until recently.
And I think you are
right to think that way,
because if you look at the world
that we lived in up until 2014,
it kind of looked like this.
So on one side we had the Linux
world, the open source world,
and the tools around it.
So for languages we
had Java, Python.
We had Apache projects.
We had Eclipse, IntelliJ as IDE.
We had MySQL as your SQL server.
You had Bash for scripting.
And there were a bunch
of other tools here.
I'm just simplifying
a little bit.
And then parallel to that,
we had the Windows world.
Now with the Windows world,
you had similar things.
So instead of Java, you had C#.
Instead of Bash,
you had PowerShell.
Instead of MySQL, you had SQL
Server, and so on and so forth.
And the unfortunate thing was
that these two worlds, they
existed side by side, but
they never really interacted.
And that was really
frustrating for me
because I started my career
as a Windows developer.
I learned all these tools.
And then at some point
I had to switch my job.
So I moved to Linux world.
I had to relearn everything.
And you could argue
which side is better.
I have my own opinions.
Like for example I think C#
is much better than Java,
for sure.
But that's not the point.
The point is that
you were trying
to solve similar problems
with almost similar tools,
but they were slightly
different enough
to make it annoying for you.
But things are changing.
If you look at what happened
in the last couple of years,
it's almost like a revolution.
First, .NET went
open source in 2014.
That was big news.
And then we gradually
started seeing
tools moving from Windows
to Linux and from Linux
to Windows.
Like for example, OpenSSH
moved from Linux to Windows.
So you could run
that on Windows.
Then we had Ubuntu and
Debian running on Azure.
After that in 2016, it was
probably the biggest year
for .NET and Windows.
We had the flagship SQL
Server now runs on Linux.
I mean if you think about that,
like three or four years ago,
you couldn't even
think about that.
And now it runs on Linux.
Similarly with PowerShell,
the PowerShell cmdlets,
they run on Linux.
And then stuff also
moving from Linux--
so Bash now runs on Windows.
And lastly-- not
lastly, but ASP.NET Core
is the most exciting
part for me.
So now you can write
your ASP.NET apps
and target Linux,
Windows, and Mac.
And that's really exciting.
And actually there's a talk
today later at 2:40 on .NET
containers that will cover this.
At the end of my session, I'm
also going to point you to all
the other talks and all the
other sessions that we have
on .NET and Windows so
you know what we have.
And then finally the year
ended with two announcements.
The first one was Microsoft
joins Linux Foundation,
and then Google joins
.NET foundation.
I think, for me,
that was kind of
like the highlight of the year.
So now when you look at the
world that we're living today,
we still have these two worlds.
So we still have two
operating systems.
But then the tools and
languages around them,
they are much more converged.
And this is really good news
for us because all the time
and effort we spent in learning
C# and learning ASP.NET,
learning PowerShell,
all that kind of stuff,
now we can apply them to Linux.
And that's great news.
So now let's talk about
what Google Cloud is
doing to help for this.
But before I do that, let's
answer the why question first.
So why should you even
deploy to Google Cloud?
And let's look at this question
from a consumer perspective.
So let's say you're
a cloud consumer.
You are shopping around.
And Google Cloud tells you
that you should deploy here.
Why should you do that?
There are many reasons,
but I think in my mind,
it boils down to
three main reasons.
The first is Google's
infrastructure.
So when you're running your
application on Google's cloud,
you are basically running
on the same infrastructure
that Google is
running, which means
that you're running
on a private network,
even between data centers.
So if you go from one data
center to another data center,
you are going through
Google's own payment network.
Which means that you have
good latency, good throughput,
and it's very stable.
So we have fast VM provisioning.
So if you want a VM, it
becomes available to you
within seconds.
And that's really
important because when
you are moving
applications to the cloud,
you want things to be elastic.
So you want to get VMs
as fast as possible.
And also autoscale-- autoscale
is also really important.
When you have lots
of load, you want
autoscale to kick in
to add more machines.
And when the load
is gone, you want
to scale down to save money.
So the autoscaling at Google
Cloud, because of the network
and because of fast
VM provisioning,
it really works really
fast and it really
helps for scaling
up and scaling down.
So that's number one.
Number two is price.
So if you're shopping
for something,
you definitely care about price.
So what we try to
do is first of all,
we try to keep our prices
as competitive as possible.
But on top of that,
we have features that
help you to save even more.
So for example, if you want
to run your VM for 10 minutes,
you pay for 10 minutes.
You don't pay for
the whole hour.
If you use your VM
for the whole month,
you get automatic
discount, up to 30%,
and you don't have to
do anything about that.
We just detect that you run
the VM for the whole month,
and we give you the
discount right away.
If you have a VM that's
with lots of CPU and memory,
but you're not really using
that, we detect your load
and let you know.
We tell you, by the way,
you can scale this VM down.
You can decrease the memory.
You can decrease the
CPU and run it cheaper
because you don't need it.
So we try to detect
what you need
and tell you how you can save.
And then the last
part is flexibility.
So you can have
custom VMs, which
means that you can
say, I want to have
a VM with lots on memory
but not so much CPU,
because that's what you need.
Or you can say I want
a VM with lots of CPU
but not so much memory.
So you customize what you need,
and you pay for what you need.
So that's great.
And also in situations where
you have like a queue of work
and you want to have VMs
just working from the queue,
we have something
called preemptible VMs.
These are VMs that
can come and go
depending on the load in
other parts of Google Cloud.
But the good thing
about them is they're
perfect for this work queue
situation where you can just
have 20 of them or 25 of them.
It doesn't really matter.
But they're up to 80%
cheaper than the regular VMs.
So these all combined, I
think, is a compelling reason
why you should care about
Google Cloud as a consumer.
But as a developer--
almost all of us are
developers here--
what's in it for you?
So let's look at that from
a developer's perspective.
So the first thing, again,
is deployment options.
If you want to run your app in
a VM, we have Compute Engine.
If you switch to
containers and you
want to have your
container cluster,
we have Container Engine.
If you don't care
about containers or VMs
and you just want
to deploy your app
and let someone else take
care of scaling it for you,
then you have App Engine.
If you don't even
care about apps
and you just want to
write your functions that
gets triggered by some trigger,
then you have Cloud Functions.
So no matter what you
want to do at what level,
we have options for you.
The second thing
is, many services.
So once you have your
app running in the cloud,
there's all these services
that becomes available to you
right away.
And the key thing about these
services that we try to do
is we try to make them
as managed as possible.
By that I mean
you-- for example,
take Pub/Sub as an example.
And Pub/Sub is a public
subscribe messaging framework.
So you create a
topic, and then you
push messages to
that topic, and then
you get messages
from that topic.
Normally if you set up
a cluster or Pub/Sub,
you need to worry
about machines.
You need to worry
about how you're
going to globally distribute
that queue and stuff like that.
Whereas in Google,
Pub/Sub basically just
creates the topic, and
all of the infrastructure
is abstracted away from you.
You don't care about how many
machines it's running on,
or you don't care
where it's running.
It's globally scaled
for you automatically.
So this is true for BigQuery.
This is true for BigTable.
So we try to make it as
devop-less as possible for you.
And then finally
most importantly I
think in my mind is
machine learning.
So machine running is
really big at Google.
We use it in most
all our products.
And we have all these models
built up using the data
that we have.
And now we are
providing this machine
learning to you through APIs.
So we have Vision API.
We have Natural
Language Processing API.
We have Speech API.
So we try to basically
make it really easy
for you to consume machine
learning from your apps.
And I'm actually
going to show you,
in the demo, an example
of how to do that.
And if you want to build your
own machine learning models,
you can run
TensorFlow, at scale,
using Google Cloud
Machine Learning.
So the last thing that I want
to talk about before I show you
code and demos is
what options do
we have as an ASP.NET
developer when you
want to deploy to Google Cloud.
So if you are a
traditional ASP.NET person,
your app is running in ASP.NET
on Windows, you can take that
and you can host that on Compute
Engine, and it's good to go.
So it's running in Compute
Engine in a VM in Google Cloud.
And the sample that
I'm going to show today
is going to show how to do this.
And then if you made
the switch from ASP.NET
to ASP.NET Core running on
Linux then you have more choice.
You can run it on App
Engine flexible environment,
or you can run it
on Container Engine.
So in App Engine
flexible environment,
you basically take us
your ASP.NET Core app,
put it in a Docker container,
and just say to App Engine,
just take this container
and run it for me at scale.
So App Engine kind of figures
out what kind of scale
do you need, and it
provisions machines.
And it load balances.
And it has versioning.
It does traffic splitting.
So there's all this
goodness built in.
All you need to do is just wrap
your application into a Docker
container and just
give it to it,
and it will just
run at it scale.
It's very easy.
And the session
in this afternoon
will show this App Engine
flexible environment later.
If you want to build your
own container cluster,
you can also wrap your
ASP.NET core application
into a container and run it on
Kubernetes in Container Engine.
So this gives you
more flexibility.
It's more involved
than App Engine.
But with that you
have more flexibility
what you can run in
your container cluster.
So this is for the upside.
So for data, if you're
using SQL Server,
you can take the SQL Server
and run it on Compute Engine.
And we support all the
versions from 2008 until 2016.
And then we have tools.
So we have a Visual
Studio plugin
where you can manage
your Google Cloud
resources from Visual Studio.
We have lots of .NET libraries
to talk to pretty much all
Google Cloud Services.
And then finally we
have PowerShell cmdlets
that lets you script your
access using PowerShell.
So no matter what
you want to do--
ASP.NET, ASP.NET
Core, SQL Server,
tools-- we try to basically
make that available to you.
And there's more and more
stuff that are coming.
So that was enough talk.
Now it's time to show you
some code and some demos.
So in this part of the
talk, I want to show you
a simple application.
First we're going to
run it on my laptop.
And then once it's
working on my laptop,
I want to show you how we
can take that application
and move it to Google Cloud.
The application that
I want to show you,
it's called Contoso University.
Maybe some of you
know this application?
Anyone knows?
No?
Maybe?
OK.
So Contoso University, it's
a fictitious university.
It's a reference application
for ASP.NET MVC 5.
So it does some simple pages
for students, for courses,
for instructors.
And it's backed by a
SQL Server instance.
And it's using MVC, so
model-view-controller 5.
So it's just a
reference application
showing how to use MVC
backed by a SQL Server.
So let's just take a
look at that quickly.
So in the demo I just want to
show you how this works locally
on my machine.
So I already have the
Contoso University solution
open on my machine.
And as I mentioned, this
is an MVC application.
Well I already have it
running, so let me just
show you that quickly here.
So this is running
locally on my machine.
If you go to students, this
is showing the students.
It's paged.
You can look at the
details of the student.
We have courses.
And then we have instructors.
So it's pretty basic.
And then just to show
you code a little bit,
so we have-- let's
start with models.
So we have models for
student, course, department.
If we look at the
person for example,
this has last name,
first name, full name.
And then student
extends from the person.
And on top of that it adds
enrollment date, enrollment.
So you know which student
belongs to which class,
stuff like that.
As you know in MVC
applications, you
have a controller that
actually controls the model.
So let's look at the
student controller.
So in StudentController, we have
basic methods for HTTP calls.
So for example, if you
get a detail or a student,
then this method gets
called with an ID.
And then we have a
db, database object.
And then from there
we find a student.
And then we just
return the view.
And then we have a bunch of
other methods for create,
creating a student,
editing a student,
and so on and so forth.
So we covered model.
We covered controller.
And then we have views.
So if you look at
the views folder,
we have separate
views for a bunch
of different things like
courses, departments, home.
But then if you look
at the student one,
it's basically just HTML.
Let's look at the
details page for example.
It's basically HTML with
some ASP.NET stuff scattered
in there.
And then one last thing
to show you is Web.config.
Oh sorry, here.
So in Web.config,
there is a LocalDb.
So the actual database is local.
So it's the SQL Server
running locally on my machine.
But we're going to change
that later to use a SQL
Server running on Google Cloud.
So this is the app.
Let me just go back to
my presentation quickly.
All right, so now I want to
take this app, running locally,
and I want to push
it to Google Cloud.
So let's see what steps
I need to do that.
First, I'm going to make
life easy for myself
and I'm going to install
Google Cloud for Visual Studio.
This will enable me to interface
with Google Cloud, create
VMs, and stuff like that.
Once I have that, this is
a traditional ASP.NET app.
So I need a Windows VM
with ASP.NET framework
already installed on it.
So I'm going to use
Visual Studio plugin
to get a VM that I need.
We also need a SQL
Server instance,
because the one that I'm
using right now is local.
So I'm going to get a SQL Server
instance on Compute Engine.
And then finally, I'm
going to publish directly
from Visual Studio.
So from Visual Studio I'm just
going to publish to the VM
that I just created.
So these are the steps.
So let's just take a look.
So in this part I'm going to--
first let me stop this.
So if you go to Tools, and
then Extensions and Updates,
this is where you can
install Visual Studio plug-in
that we have for Google Cloud.
So I'll go here.
I click on Online.
This searches Visual
Studio gallery.
So here I'm just going
to type, Google Cloud.
And as you can see, this
is the extension I want.
It's already installed for
me, because I have it here.
But if it's not,
you can double click
and it will install
it right here.
Then you need to
restart Visual Studio.
So once you do that,
you go to Tools.
And then you see this
Google Cloud tool.
So this is the
plug-in that basically
lets you access Google Cloud.
First you need to
add your account
so that Visual Studio
is authenticated
with Google Cloud.
You go to Accounts,
and then Add Account.
This opens a new
browser and it asks me,
which account do
you want to use?
I want to use my
development account.
And then Allow.
And now Visual
Studio is authorized
to access my account,
which is great.
I go back here.
It tells me that your account is
already here, because I already
added my account here.
That's OK.
And now if I go to Tools
and Google Cloud Tools,
I do Show Google Cloud Explorer.
Now this is me.
And then these are my projects
that I have under my account.
I'm going to look at the
.NET project that I have.
Under here I can see all the
VM instances that I have,
all the storage and SQL.
So there is going to
be more stuff here.
And it's coming up.
But for now we just show Compute
Engine, clusters, Cloud SQL.
But in the feature
you basically will
be able to see all your
resources from here.
So what I need to do here
is first, as I told you,
I need to have a Windows
VM with ASP.NET framework.
So let's try to get that.
What I'm going to
do is I'm going
to right click here and just
say new ASP.NET instance.
And this takes me to
Google Cloud Console.
And then there's
called Cloud Launcher,
which is like a marketplace
for solutions on Google Cloud.
And one of those solutions
is called ASP.NET Framework.
So this will enable me
to install Windows--
get a Windows VM with ASP.NET
framework with basically one
click.
So I'm just going to say
Launch on Compute Engine.
And then let's just call this
ASP.NET GCP Next San Francisco.
You can choose your zone.
I just choose US West.
You can customize
your machine type.
You have like 2008, 2012, 2016.
I'll choose 2016.
And then you can
customize your disk size,
all that kind of stuff.
And then I just hit Deploy.
And now within a
couple of minutes,
this will give me a Windows
VM with ASP.NET framework
installed.
Now I already have one, so let
me just show you that quickly.
If I go under Compute
Engine, I already
have this
contoso-original as my VM.
So we can actually RDP into
that, so let's do that.
And I'll enter my credentials.
And I just RDPed into
the Windows VM server
that I got ready
before this talk.
These VMs, they have
Cloud SDK installed.
And they have Server Manager.
So just a regular VM running
in the cloud, all right?
The second thing
I need-- so this
will go on for a little bit,
but we'll use this one for now.
The second thing I
need is a SQL Server.
To get SQL Server in the
cloud, what I need to do
is now right click on
Compute Engine again.
But instead of
ASP.NET Instance, I'm
going to just say New Instance.
So this is going to
be a bit different.
And it takes me
to the right place
again in Google Cloud Console.
And what I'm going to do
is I'm going to call this
instance-sql-server-gcpnext.
And then I'll choose
my zone to US West.
And then the boot
disk, right now it's
pointing to a Linux instance.
I don't want a Linux instance.
I want a SQL Server instance.
So under here, you can
see all the OS images,
including Windows images here.
But what I want is application.
And then under here you have
all the SQL Server instances.
So I'm just going to
choose, let's say,
SQL Server 2016 Standard.
And then hit Select.
And I can just keep
the default create.
So with this, I'm
going to get a SQL
Server within a couple of
minutes running in the cloud.
Again, I deployed
this SQL Server before
and I configured it already.
So let me just log in and
show you how that looks.
So the SQL Server
instances, by default
they come with SQL
Server Management Studio.
So I'm in the VM right now.
And as you can see, this
is my SQL Server instance,
and these are the databases
that I created for this demo.
So it's pretty standard, the
stuff that you got used to,
but they are now
running in the cloud.
All right, so that's good.
Let me get out of here.
Now what I want to do is, I
basically want to take my app
and deploy it to the
cloud now, right?
First thing I need to do is,
let's go back to Visual Studio.
Let's close this.
I need to change Web.config to
point to the SQL Server that's
running in the cloud
instead of the local db one.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to comment this out.
And then I'm going
to add this in.
The IP is the IP of
the SQL Server instance
that I already have running.
And I already created a
user and a database there.
So I'm just using that.
So that's number one.
And second thing is I need
to tell Visual Studio how
to publish this
application to the cloud.
So to do that, I need the
publish settings file.
So I'm going to go to Tools,
and then Show Cloud Explorer.
So this is the VM that
I want to publish to.
So I'm just going to right click
and say, Save public settings.
And let's just
save it to desktop.
So it's saved.
And then, I'm going to right
click on this app, and then
Publish.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to just import the publish
settings that I just
downloaded.
Let's just point to there,
desktop, and it was this one.
So as you can see, all the
IP details and username
and password, they're
already filled for me.
Let's just validate, make sure
that I have the connection.
It's green.
That's good.
I'm just going to check this
guy, and then hit Publish.
Now it will wrap
up my application,
and then it will just publish to
the VM running in Google Cloud.
And it should just take a couple
of seconds, publish succeeded.
And if we go here and then
I click on the external IP,
it's the same application.
And if we go to students,
it's the same application,
but it's running in the cloud
and talking to a SQL Server
also running in the cloud.
So that's what it
takes, basically,
to take your application
and publish to Google Cloud.
So I'll go back to
my presentation.
Let's do it at the end.
So we moved our application
to Google Cloud.
Now I want to take
it to the next level.
So what I want to do is,
first, these students,
they don't have any
pictures, right?
So I want to add some profile
pictures for students.
But you need a
space to save them.
So I'm going to use Google
Cloud Storage for that.
So I'm going to use
Google Cloud Storage,
create a bucket there, and
save the pictures there.
But saving pictures for
every single student
is going to take a long
time, one by one, especially
if you have a big university.
So thankfully we have PowerShell
cmdlets that you can basically
use to script things.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to use PowerShell cmdlet
and move the pictures to the
bucket I want using the cmdlet.
Then you know
students can be funny.
They can upload any
kind of pictures.
So maybe they'll try to upload
violent pictures or adult
pictures.
And I want to prevent
that from happening.
So what I'm going to do is
there's this machine learning
API called Vision API.
You can give it an
image, and it gives you
annotations about that
image, so everything
it knows about that image.
And we're going
to use that Vision
API to detect if
an image is violent
or adult image or
something like that
and prevent that student
from uploading that image.
And then finally I want
to add some fun facts
about the student, so something
interesting about the student.
But I want to make this
so that student can speak,
and we will detect
from their voice,
and we will convert
that to text,
and then we will enter
that as fun facts.
Doing this on your own,
it's not that easy.
But I can use something
called Speech API.
It's another machine learning
API where you can basically
pass in a file with
some sound and then
it extracts the text for you.
So that's what I want to
add to my application.
So let's take a look
at our code again.
All right, so what I'm
going to show you is,
first let's look at
the profile picture.
So let me just find
the code for that.
First I created a service.
And I called it ImageUploader.
So this is a really
simple service.
Let's see if you can
see that properly.
So this service, one
thing you're going to note
is that it's using
Google Cloud Storage.
This is a NuGet library
that you can reference
from your application.
And with that, you get
access to Cloud Storage.
And this ImageUploader,
it basically
takes in a bucket name,
because in clusters you
need to have a bucket
to save images.
And then it creates
a StorageClient.
So this is the guy
that we're going to use
to talk to Cloud Storage.
And then it has two methods.
One method is
called UploadImage.
And the other one is
called DeleteImage.
Because when you
delete the student,
you want to delete
the image as well.
So the UploadImage, it
basically takes in an image
and it takes in an ID.
So this is the ID of a student.
And it uses Cloud Storage
to upload the image.
And it basically just
says, take this image,
save it to this
bucket with this ID.
And then this is the source.
And make sure that the
image is publicly readable.
So with one call you can upload
the image to Cloud Storage.
And then if you look at
the DeleteUploadedImage,
again it takes in an ID
and then uses StorageClient
to delete the image.
So it's very basic.
And what I also
changed is that if you
look at student controller,
I added an ImageUploader.
And I'm going to talk
about the SafeImageUploader
in a little bit.
And then if you look
here for example,
this is the Create method.
This is when the
student is created.
What we are doing is if
an image has been passed,
then use ImageUploader to upload
that image with the student ID.
And then this will
return you a path.
It's a public URL basically.
And that will set that as
the student image path.
So with that, we can
have profile pictures.
So let me just show
you how this works.
This is the one.
So I have it running
locally already.
I'll go to students.
And let's just
create a new student.
And I'll just add
myself as a student.
I'll talk about fun
facts afterwards.
But let's just choose a picture.
I'll choose one of my pictures.
And let me just
change just to 2017.
Hit Create.
So this will basically
take my picture,
upload it to Cloud Storage,
and then save it as image path.
And if I look at the
student list, I am here.
details, I have a picture.
OK, that's good, but having
these pictures for each student
and uploading them
one by one, it's
going to take a while, right?
So what I want to
do now is I want
to use PowerShell cmdlets
that we have to script this,
so that we can upload a
bunch of images all at once.
When you install
Google Cloud SDK,
you have these
cmdlets by default.
So you have them by default.
So I have it here already.
So let me just show you
this PowerShell cmdlet.
So it's called upload pictures.
And then it also has a picture
folder right next to it.
So what we're doing here
is that I have a bucket.
So this is the bucket that I
want to save in Cloud Storage.
And this is my
folder of pictures.
And all I'm saying is
that New-GcsObject.
So Gcs stands for
Google Cloud Storage.
So basically what
this command does
is take this folder and
upload to this bucket,
and make sure that they
are publicly readable.
And then I do this
by New-GcsObject.
And then basically
just run this.
And let's just do that
and see how that looks.
So this is working.
In here, if I can
show you, there's
a bunch of other cmdlets, like
Add-GcsBucket, Add-GcsObject.
So these are all
Google Cloud PowerShell
cmdlets that you can
use in your scripting.
As you can see, it's already
looking at the images
and uploading them.
And if we go back
to our console,
and I go to here
and Cloud Storage,
I have a bunch of buckets
for all my projects.
But the one I care
about is called Contoso.
I click here.
And you can see that the
folder is already uploaded
with a bunch of pictures.
And I can use these
pictures, change my code
so that they can refer to these
pictures and just use them.
So the next thing
I want to show you
is, so these pictures can
be anything right now.
So a student can upload
any kind of picture.
And we want to prevent that.
We want to make sure these
pictures are not violent,
they're not adult pictures.
So to do that, I want
to use Vision API.
So let me go back to code again.
What I did is I created
another service called
ImageSafetyChecker.
So this guy, I get first--
oh, come on.
This guy, it's using
the Vision API library.
So it's a NuGet package
again that you can install.
And then it has a client again
called ImageAnnotatorClient.
So this is a client that you
use to talk to Vision API.
So when we create this
ImageSafetyChecker,
we create the client as well.
And then it has a simple
method called IsSafe.
So given a file,
this takes this file,
and then passes it to
the ImageAnnotatorClient,
right here.
And this basically
calls Vision API
and gets some annotations
about that image.
And then the annotations, they
have four dimensions, adult,
violent, spoof, or medical.
So what I'm doing here is
that-- and these annotations,
they're enums.
So they can change
from very unlikely,
to unlikely, possible,
likely, or very unlikely.
So given an image, it
basically tells you
this image is very likely that
it's an adult image, or very
unlikely that it's a violent
image, stuff like that.
So what I'm doing here
is that I am basically
just checking all
the dimensions,
and making sure that
their likelihood is
less than possible, so
that it's not possible
that they're adult or violence.
So this method will basically
give me the safety that I need.
And then what I did
is that, remember
we had the ImageUploader
to upload our images?
I created another one
called SafeImageUploader.
And it extends
from ImageUploader.
And then the only
thing that it adds
is that it basically
has a reference
to this ImageSafetyChecker.
And when we upload the image,
instead of uploading that image
right away, we call the
ImageSafetyChecker and ask,
is this image safe?
If it's not safe, we
throw an exception.
And then otherwise we
just upload the image.
So with this, I have the safety
that I need to upload my image.
And then if we go to
StudentController,
I show you before,
instead of creating
a regular ImageUploader, I'm
creating a SafeImageUploader.
So by default I'm using
the safety feature.
Now let me just show
you how that works.
So go back to my app.
I think it was this one.
So let me edit this.
And then let me just choose
another image, this one.
This is like a guy shooting.
So it's kind of violent I guess.
So let's see if we can stop
this from being uploaded.
So I choose that.
It saved.
And then it says, oh, Unable to
save changes, blah, blah, blah.
Because I had that exception--
because of the exception,
I could not upload the image.
So it's pretty easy.
And then the last thing I want
to show you is the fun facts.
So as you can see, there's
some fun facts here
that you can add some
text about the student.
What I want to do is
have this Record button.
You can click on
it and talk to it,
and it will detect your
voice, convert it to text,
and then edit here.
So to do that, what
I did is I created
a couple of more services.
So the first one is
called VoiceRecorder.
So this is not that interesting.
It basically has a method
called RecordFromMicrophone,
with seconds.
So you provide some seconds,
like say three seconds,
and it records your voice from
microphone for three seconds.
And it saves it to a file.
That's all it does.
So there's nothing fancy here.
But the other one,
VoiceRecognizer, it's
much more interesting.
First, it's using the
Google Cloud Speech library.
And then it has something
called SpeechClient.
So as you can see, all
the services that we have,
they have the same pattern.
They have a NuGet package.
And then they have a
client that you create.
And then you use that
client to talk to it.
So in this case, it's
the Speech client.
And then it has a
method called Recognize.
So what it does is
that it basically just,
using the Speech client, it
calls SyncRecognizeAsync,
and pass in some
parameters, that
are usually the default ones.
And then you provide a
file path, so the file path
of your recording.
And then, this gets sent to
the Speech API in Google Cloud.
And that returns some results.
So usually when you pass in your
voice, you have one result back
and you could just use that.
But sometimes depending on
how clear your voice is,
you might have multiple results
with multiple alternatives.
And each alternative has
its own confidence level.
So you would look
at the alternatives
and pick the one that has
the highest confidence.
But in this case,
I'm just looking
at the first alternative
and just returning
that, the first one,
because this is just a demo.
All right, that's good.
And then what I lastly changed
is in StudentController,
I created a new
method called Record.
So when you click
that button, it
gets called here,
with the student ID.
I find the student.
And then I use the voice
recorder to record my voice
for three seconds.
That saves to a file.
Then I pass that file
to a VoiceRecognizer
that I just wrote, and
just say Recognize.
And that gives me, from
the voice, the text.
I get the text back.
And then I just set that as
the fun facts of the students.
So let's try this out.
So here I'm just going
to say something.
Let's see if it works.
He is cool.
Oh, I don't know if it worked.
I'll try one more time.
Maybe the microphone
is not hooked in.
He is cool.
Ah, yeah, it worked, cool.
So hit Save.
And that's it.
All right, so I'll go
back to my presentation.
And let's see, I
have some time left.
So this is fun.
As you can see, we moved our
application to the cloud.
And with that, we get all
these services almost for free.
And then with a couple
of lines of code,
we use machine learning
to detect images
if they are bad images.
And then we did speech to text.
But now you need to take your
application into production,
right?
We have some problems
with this application.
For example, first of
all, this application
just runs on one
VM in the cloud.
If that VM goes down, you
have no way of knowing that.
So what you actually
need is health checks.
You need to add health
checks to make sure
that you know if your
application is healthy or not.
There's no logging right now.
So you're kind of blind.
Thankfully there's something
called Stackdriver Logging
in Google Cloud that gives
you centralized logging,
not just in Google Cloud, but
across other cloud providers
as well.
So we'll start Stackdriver
Logging to our application.
There's no error reporting.
So if there's an error, if
we don't know about that,
there's something called
Stackdriver Error Reporting
that basically captures all
the errors in your application
and then gives you a
centralized dashboard
to look at all your errors, when
they happened, how often they
happened, stuff like that.
So we'll add that.
And then our application
is not resilient
because it's just one instance.
If we have more load
coming in, one instance
is not going to cover that.
We need multiple
instances, load balanced.
And we need autoscaling
actually to make this work.
Thankfully there's something
called instant groups
in Google Cloud that
makes this really easy.
So we're going to
add an instance group
and have all of this
happen magically for us.
So just to talk about the
scaling in Google Cloud,
so this is what
we had initially.
I had my application
running locally.
Then I pushed it to a single
VM running in Google Cloud.
So what you can do
from that point on
is that you can take that VM
and create a snapshot out of it.
It's called an instance image.
So this is kind of like a
snapshot of your application.
And then from the image, you
create an instance template.
So a template is like a
blueprint for your application.
It's a blueprint of
how you can create
the same app on a different VM.
So once you have the
instance template,
from there you can
create an instance group.
And this is where all
the magic happens.
Basically with
instance group, you
will get multiple VMs, load
balanced behind that load
balancer.
And they have health checks.
So the load balancer uses the
health check to check your app.
And then it also
has autoscaling.
So if you need to have
more than one instance,
it will automatically scale.
So an instance group basically
gives you all the stuff
that you need to run your
application in production.
I'm just going to
show you quickly
what are the steps for
you to set this up.
All right, so let me first
show you the health check.
First, for the health check,
I created a new controller
called PingController.
So this PingController,
it's very simple right now.
Basically when you hit the
endpoint, you get a pong back.
Normally in a real
world application,
you want to check
your dependencies
and make sure they're healthy
before you can return OK.
But in this case, I'm just
returning OK no matter what.
I also created another
endpoint with some ID.
And I am just saying--
I'm just throwing
an error because I
want to show you how this works
in Google Stackdriver Error
Reporting.
So I have this PingController.
And actually if I go back to my
app, I think it was this one.
And if I do api/ping,
yeah, it just
tells me pong,
nothing interesting.
But what you can do is you can
go to Google Cloud Console,
and under Compute Engine,
and then Health Checks,
you can create a health check.
I already have one.
But let me just show you how
that health check looks like.
You basically just say,
this is an HTTP health check
with port 80.
And this is the
endpoint that I want
to hit to make sure
that it's healthy.
And then these are the
criteria for my health check.
So I'm going to check
every 30 seconds.
And if I get OK two
times, I'm going
to assume that it's healthy.
If I get errors two
times, I'm going
to assume it's not
healthy, stuff like that.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to use this health check
to create our instance group.
And then when the load balancer
gets created with the instance
group, it will use
this health check
to determine whether
our instance is healthy.
So that's one.
Let me go here.
Second thing I want to
show you is Stackdriver.
So let me just find the code.
So first, I created something
called StackdriverLogger.
So the original logger
of the application,
it basically just uses trace.
But I don't want trace.
I want my logs to go
to a central place
so I can look at them.
So with Stackdriver,
all I had to do
was, again, use
the NuGet package.
So this is the NuGet package
for Stackdriver logging.
And then from there, I
just create a client.
Again, it's the same
kind of paradigm
you referenced in
the NuGet package.
You have a client.
So once I have the client,
I just use this to log.
So by logging with this
client, I have my logs central
in Google Cloud.
So that's number one.
The second thing
is error reporting.
So I want all my errors
to be caught and sent
to Google Cloud.
So to do that, in
WebApiConfig, I just registered
Stackdriver Error Reporting.
So it's basically
just one line of code.
And all I'm saying
here is that when
there's an exception,
this kind of exception,
which is like the
main exception class,
just basically just report
that exception to this project,
to this service,
to this version.
So everything that's
thrown from my application
will be caught and
sent to Google Cloud.
So let's just show these
quickly in the console.
So if you go back to Console,
go to Stackdriver, here.
Let's look at the logging first.
So Stackdriver logs
have a lot of stuff.
But in this case, my
application is a GCE,
Google Compute Engine instance.
And this is my
application, so this
is where it's going to log.
And as you can see
here, these are my logs.
So these are my SQL
statements from my app.
So it's already
going to Stackdriver
because I implemented
Stackdriver logger,
and it works.
And then to look at
the error reporting,
I'll go to Error Reporting.
And let's go back to our apps,
and just hit that endpoint
that will throw me an error.
So let's just say ping/1.
And this threw an exception.
Yes, we are here.
OK, continue.
So this threw an exception.
So if we come back here--
and I think I need
to autoreload.
As you can see, it just says oh,
it's just seen this exception.
It's seen in Contoso
application version 1.
And if I click on it,
I get more details.
So I only have it
not work today.
But if you have it
failing like a month,
you can see when it
happened, how it happened,
what was its stack trace,
all that kind of stuff that
becomes available to you.
With just one line of code,
you can catch all of this,
and then it's right here.
I think this is really good.
And then the last thing I want
to show you is the instance
groups and autoscaling.
So to do that, what I had to
do is go to Compute Engine.
First, I need to create a
snapshot over my application.
So I need to create an image.
So here, I have images.
And then as you can see
there's the contoso-gcp one.
This is the one that I created.
There are instructions on
how to create this image,
but it's pretty basic basically.
You just go to your Windows
VM instance, run a command,
and it shuts down.
And then from
there you just say,
create an image from
this persistent disk.
And you have your image.
And you can share that
image with other people,
with other projects,
stuff like that.
So once you have
this image, then you
need to create a
template, a blueprint
of how to create that image
and use it in other VMs.
So I have instance templates.
So here it is,
contoso-gcp-template
that I created before this talk.
And this guy, basically
the important thing
is that it's using the image
I just showed you about.
And it has some configuration
that you can set.
And that's it.
You There's not much to it.
And then you can also specify
what kind of APIs and things
that it can use.
And that's it.
So I have my template.
So from this template, now I
can create an instance group.
So I have five minutes left.
So I just want to
show you that quickly.
In Instance Groups, I
created an instance group.
And if we just edit
that instance group,
so this is where all
the magic happens.
First, it's using the
template I created.
And then autoscaling is on.
So by just setting
this on, I got
autoscaling, which is great.
It is using load balancing.
So it's HTTP load
balancing on port 80.
I can specify how many
instances I want by default.
But minimum, I will have
one instance by minimum.
And then for this demo,
I said three instances.
So it will autoscale
to three instances.
But you can set that
to whatever you want.
And then, it's also
using health check.
So it's using the health check
that I defined to make sure
that my instances are healthy.
So with this, I get pretty
much everything I want.
My application is much
more ready to production.
And we have all the pieces
basically to make this happen.
So now I want to go
back to presentation
and just point a couple of
things before I finish my talk.
So summary, what do we do?
We started with an ASP.NET
app running locally.
We moved to a Windows
server running
in the cloud, SQL Server
running in the cloud.
We added pictures
with Cloud Storage.
We added intelligence with
Vision API, Speech API.
And we made it production ready
with instance groups, load
balancing, autoscaling,
Stackdriver, things like that.
But there's much more.
So if you go to
cloud.google.com/dotnet slash
windows, there's much
more information.
There's a codelabs
page, but there are also
codelabs here at Next
where you can actually
do this stuff hands on.
And I'm going to be there.
And if you have any questions,
I'll be there as well.
Talks at Next-- so the
first one was my talk.
And then we have a talk in the
afternoon on .NET containers,
another one at SQL
Server at the same time.
Then tomorrow we have a
Windows-based talk as well.
And tomorrow from
1:00 to 4:00 PM,
there's a meet the experts area.
And I'm going to be there where
we're going to have .NET people
basically.
So any questions that you have
about .NET on Google Cloud,
we're going to be there.
And as I said at the
beginning of my talk,
I think it's a great time
to be a .NET developer.
Thanks for your time.
And if you want
books, I have books.
Yeah, that was it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]